[Music]
the basic thesis of this book which is
called the first that's the title
meaning the first amendment so it's
directed largely I have freedom of
speech issues as they turn up in the
United States but in fact there's a huge
overlap between United Kingdom in the
United States and many other countries
all dealing with the same problems that
are finally produced by the doctrine of
free speech and this book at least in
the first chapter asked the question
well what exactly is the doctrine of
free speech and the answer I gave us
nothing at all there's no such thing as
free speech something that I said years
ago but now I can amplify that by saying
free speech is not a thing it's not an
ideal it's not a principle it's a
rhetoric it's a ragtag bag of sayings
and invocations that people employ on
particular occasions some political some
not political and when that has been
employed when that bad ragtag bag of
rhetoric names free speech has been
employed are you then move on to the
next situation where a so-called free
speech issue has emerged and you employ
another bag of charcoal tricks that's it
there's nothing there I was like put it
in this book again with reference to the
First Amendment there's nothing inside
the First Amendment it's an absolutely
empty shell now I'm not going to make
that point today although I've already
made I just wanted to give you the
background or the questions that I do
want to discuss with you which have to
deal with how talk about freedom of
speech and the supposed curtailment of
freedom speech turns up in our colleges
and university
what's going on when free speech is
invoked and where accusations fly back
and forth between rival parties each of
which says to the other you are tearing
down free speech and the response is
always no you are tearing down free
speech I don't know whether any of you
have never been a party to these campus
I can only call them campus follies but
they are all depressingly the same and
I'm going to try to shed some light on
them with your help
back in May I believe yeah I think it
was in May
now it was in March President Donald
Trump you've heard of him announced he
was going to require colleges and
universities to support freedom of
speech if they wish to receive federal
research funds you got that that of
course is the assumption behind what
Trump is saying that free speech is a
cornerstone a key core part of the
academic enterprise now many people in
the Academy all of whom are always
scurrying for cover when anything
happens especially people who head
academic associations or who are
academic administrators a particularly
Craven greed of a blender who answer
posturing like Trump's with posturing
usually weak and that's always what
happens so here's a guy whom I don't
know he's not an old enemy of mine but
maybe when he hears about this he'll be
a new enemy of mine one can always hope
his name is Terry härtel and I apologize
if his mother's in the audience
he's a senior vice president of
something called the American Council of
education
both pompous and vague and he says no on
American campuses free speech is already
a Covelli
so that's the opposition Trump saying
that universities and colleges are not
living up to their free speech
obligations Hartle saying yes we are
what I'm saying is that universities and
colleges have no free speech obligation
and that it is a mistake to think that
they do because free speech is not the
business at universities and colleges
are him and reporting in a almost
proverbial nutshell free speech is not
an academic value that's the bottom line
assertion here free speech is not an
academic value and therefore if that's
correct and because I haven't proven it
or even argued for it to be direct
current merely by declaring it but if
that turns out to be correct
then it's odd that a president would be
claiming to take away university funds
because it wasn't supporting something
that wasn't part of its mission and
enterprise in the first place and it's
out of still that a defender of the
university would fall in with the
president's assumptions about the
inextricable relationship between free
speech and what we do in colleges and
universities so why do I say this why do
I say that free speech is not an
academic value in order to answer that
question I'll have to ask you a question
which is that which is very simple if we
do accept that free speech is at least
in the political context a value and
something people usually celebrate and
want to save god
what exactly is in a political context
remember eyerly er said that free speech
is nothing in the sense
that there's nothing a core or essential
inside it but that doesn't mean that
there's nothing to be said about it in
the context in which freedom of speech
is invoked and given shape by those
contexts as as opposed to having a shape
of its own before entering any context I
hope that I've been sufficiently obscure
by that statement John Stuart Mill's on
Liberty especially chapter 2 of that
book is the philosophical underpinning
of free speech doctrine in the United
States and elsewhere Mill is devoted to
democratic deliberation to conversation
and what what according to mill and
others should be the hallmarks of that
conversation
what about entry into the conversation
in a democratic society what what does
free speech doctrine of the political
kind tell us about entry anybody enters
it because it's free speech not only in
the sense that it freely flows but it's
free in that anyone is free to engage in
it now of course if you speak freely in
your marriage sanctions believe me Oh 41
years of experience here actually 61
because I had a wife previously but
we'll forget about that as I'm sure she
has no one the state cannot punish you
for offering an opinion even an opinion
which the officials of the state
disapprove of what about the way in
which voices that enter the conversation
are weighted our given consideration
again theoretically your voice you know
some the chairman of the philosophy
department at Yale University the owner
of a large corporation the the
proprietor of a corner convenience
market all voices are welcomed into the
conversation and then once the voices
are in is
as do in fact get in what happens how
does how does all of this you know
proliferation of speech yet sorted out
there's a phrase you often use to
preside over the process by which we
listen to each other and attempt to
separate the truth from the false it's
called the marketplace of ideas have you
heard that some of you have not well
it's the marketplace of ideas the idea
is that in the marketplace of ideas all
of your all voices deserve to be heard
none should be either anointed in
advance as holy and without possibility
without the possibility of refutation
but none should be dismissed in advance
and center way as being unworthy to be
heard so there you have the in a very
rough and ready form the democratic
political conception of free speech its
value and the way it is supposed to work
in the cost of the marketplace of ideas
working itself up the truth will emerge
the truth will emerge in the light of
conversational day to continue watching
this video click the link in the top
left or in the description below or
visit a IDOT TV for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas